from Christmas pizzas to elf donuts we
wanted to find out all the differences
between fast food holiday menus in the
US and the UK this is food
Wars let's start with some McDonald's
seasonal items in the UK we actually
have quite a few of these we're going to
start with the Chicken Big Mac they
brought this into the UK menu like a
year ago as a kind of temporary thing
and it was really popular it is a Big
Mac but instead of the beef patties you
have chicken patties so it goes bun
Patty lettuce sauce pickles the middle
bun the Patty cheese pickles sauce and
lettuce mhm obviously like the ratio I
think of the Big Mac has been perfected
over the years so they haven't messed
with that too much my only real
complaint is that instead of like an
actual piece of chicken breast it's like
a big very flat chicken nugget I also
have some questions as to how festive
this is and why it's on the festive menu
obviously the box is kind of like
festive design I mean what is a chicken
if not just a small turkey next up we
have the big and cheesy not the the big
cheesy the big and cheesy look at that
and we also have the big cheesy with
bacon you have a beef patty you have two
slices of cheese you have red onions
crispy onions lettuce and cheese sauce I
mean I like cheese I like onions I like
beef it's also served in a bun which
they describe as snowflake flour dusted
which I guess is maybe their attempt at
making this actually festive and
justifying its inclusion on the
menu the star of the show for me is
actually the cheese sauce that they've
added there personally I'm a big fan I
think it's great add a lovely like
texture and really I guess slightly fake
but very comforting cheesy flavor to the
Burger in the UK at McDonald's we
usually have mozzarella sticks as kind
of like a permanent menu item but for
Christmas they turn into these the
cheese melt Dippers these are cam bear
instead of mozzarella they usually come
with a tomato dip as well although I
think they forgot our will usually like
go out of my way to try and find these
around Christmas in the UK as with
pretty much anything that is made with
fried cheese they're much better eaten
fresh and
hot still a little bit gooey and very
tasty C be is such a lovely flavor I
think I consider Bree cheese festive
strangely enough not usually C and bear
although I think it's traditional to
like have a cheeseboard around Christmas
so maybe C and bear is included on that
and we can allow it the other hot food
option we can get but we didn't get
today is the McDonald's chicken combo
this includes 10 chicken selects which
are kind of like our chicken tenders 20
chicken nuggets four select dips which
are like fancier versions of the dip and
then four regular dips it's designed to
serve around four people the next menu
item is the first of a kind of themed
batch basically what they've done is
incorporate Galaxy chocolate into
various McDonald's menu items Galaxy for
those who don't know is kind of the Mars
corporation's answer to dairy milk
there's a bit of a divide in the UK as
to whether you're Galaxy or dairy milk
when it comes to your milk chocolate so
this is the Galaxy caramel pie so what
they do is they take the apple pie shell
put some chocolate in that dough fry it
and then instead of the apple sauce you
have caramel sauce on the inside I mean
I love McDonald's apple pies they're so
good I don't really want to mess with
the
formula I think for me I still just want
the apple pie I don't think this beats
an apple pie for me then we have a
Galaxy chocolate McFlurry again it's
just kind of a standard McFlurry but
with these actually very cute chocolate
Stars which are made of Galaxy chocolate
in addition to the Galaxy chocolate
options they also have Galaxy caramel
options you can find these in the form
of the McFlurry but also in the form of
a caramel latte and also a caramel hot
chocolate I'm also not sure why Galaxy
or Galaxy caramel are festive I guess
like we eat a lot of chocolate around
the holidays but specifically Galaxy
yeah not so sure I wish our McDonald's
had as many holiday additions as the UK
does but we only have one and it's the
holiday pie so it's like their regular
pie crust and what looks like a bunch of
rainbow sprinkles and some sort of
creamy maybe custardy filling what's
inside well I don't think this will live
up to the apple pie at all
actually just get the apple
pie as always Starbucks has gone big for
the holidays in the US you can get a
bunch of limited edition food and drink
options let's start with the drinks I
love this job we have so many hot and
iced drinks couldn't get them all here
is a fantastic selection of said drinks
I just going to start down here y'all
the caramel brulee
latte better than you think another
holiday episodes youve probably seen me
really ba humbug a lot of these drinks
but maybe I'm getting older maybe I'm
getting Kinder or maybe the show has
completely destroyed my palette but
either way I kind of like that next up
the sugar cookie almond milk
latte sugar cookie apparently is just a
shorthand for sweet this is pretty sweet
I'm kind of getting an almond flavor
from it in the latte but it really just
tastes like a sweet latte I don't
dislike it but just okay next up is the
Chestnut pring latte we've been doing
this for 3 years now this might be the
fourth and I still am not quite clear
what a Praying
is if he handed this to me I'd be like
yeah it's got a kind of a a Nutty latte
taste to it but I could also see this
being just another almond latte yeah
these two are very very similar unless
you have a taste for chestnuts and
preing or a chestnut preing eh skip it
ginger bread
latte yeah man very Ginger bre not to be
confused with just Ginger definitely
jenerous with the bread part what oh man
these lattes are hidden boy they are
hidden gingerbread oat milk
chai I really like this you're so good
the ginger yes the bread yes the oat
milk oh yeah and the chai oh the
chai fantastic that might be my favorite
one so of course you get this one iced o
ice look they even put the little nutmeg
or whatever on top or it cinnamon what
is that do we know what that is yeah
hope that's supposed to be in
there no not as good as this one this of
course is not the only holiday drinks at
Starbucks depending where you are in the
world or where you are in California or
where you are in Burbank California
specifically you can get any variety of
these the olto gingerbread oat milk
latte that's one with olive oil I would
suggest you avoid those iced sugar
cookie latte peppermint mocha white
chocolate mocha peppermint mocha uh iced
also known as an ice peppermint mocha
caramel brulee Frappuccino white
chocolate mocha Frappuccino iced caramel
Brule latte Chestnut praline Frappuccino
peppermint mocha Frappuccino and an iced
peppermint mocha here are all the
Starbucks exclusive holiday items that
you'll find in the UK but not the us as
usual Starbucks has gone big for the
holidays a few of these are familiar
ones that we might have covered in
previous years but there are a couple of
new additions as well we'll start with
the hot drinks where we have a couple of
options which you'll only find around
the holidays obviously all of these are
also served in the Starbucks holiday cup
but first we have an eggnog latte this
is one that we've had before in the UK
eggnog not super popular in the UK I
gather like not even that popular in the
US I think it's just like a few people
are kind of holding on to it as a
tradition it's okay it's like not
offensive by any means it's just like a
sort of spiced almost custody but just
kind of just like a spiced milky latte
doesn't taste of egg then we have a
toffee nut latte which is another
returning
drink God every year I get my hopes up
about this one thinking it's going to be
good cuz I like toffee I like nuts and
then I take my first Sip and good God if
you've ever like been trying to toast
hazelnuts for example and you've burned
them that's what this tastes like it's
just a very sweet latte that tastes tast
like burned hazelnuts next up we have
the caramel waffle latte which is
another
returner does it taste of
waffle not really I think they almost
mean more like the Stroop waffle that
you might find in the Netherlands rather
than like a sort of breakfast waffle but
it doesn't really taste of either of
those things it just kind of tastes of
caramel so the first three drinks we've
had before but we have two new drinks
this year firstly we have the hazelnut
crunch hot
chocolate h
okay so there are like things floating
in
it which I think at one point might have
been crunchy however you don't have to
be a genius to know that when you put
crunchy things in liquid they often
soften maybe go back to the uh research
and development until you can find a
hydrophobic crunchy substance and then
our next new drink is the chocolaty
gingerbread latte see how they've
managed to uh marry these like three
beverages not well is the answer to
that it's mostly gingerbread with a kind
of like that bitterness from the coffee
also just a quick note if you have the
venty eggnog latte that contains 52.8 g
of sugar which is more than 100% of your
daily recommended intake probably my
last eggnog latte of the season and for
the Fest of treats at Starbucks in the
US you can get in no particular order
this peppermint brownie cake
pop the cranberry bliss bar we got a
slice you can also get this in this
whole tray in box form and a sugar plum
cheese
danish you know I'm curious about this
cake
pop yeah that's nice I like
that so
good I'm not getting like sugar pumps
specifically out of it yeah cheese
danish with a nice little Jam in the
center why not right also depending
Where You Are in the country you can get
a snowman cookie or a gingerbread loaf
this year I think we might actually have
more festive items than America which is
pretty cool doesn't happen often on food
Wass we'll start with the sandwiches
here we have a turkey and chicken
sandwich there's also bacon some
stuffing some cranberry sauce as well as
some spinach in there it seems a bit
weird to combine very similar Meats I
guess maybe people make like a tur
duckin and all that sort of stuff but I
think just have one or the other just
have like a good turkey sandwich next up
we have the holiday ham sub roll sub
roll submarine roll cuzz the bun is
supposed to look slightly like a
submarine this one has honey roast ham
mature cheddar cheese honey and a
mustard SLO with cranberry Chutney and
spinach the default seems to be adding
spinach and cranberry Chutney to all of
these to make them festive I'm slightly
more into the hot sandwich options so
here we have the pigs under blankets
sandwich obviously in the UK we have
pigs in blankets which are sausages
wrapped in bacon rather than the
American way which is wrapping a sausage
in some pastry the these aren't pigs in
blankets because the sausages aren't
wrapped they are pigs under blankets
because I think the bacon is added as a
separate layer on top although it's kind
of hermetically sealed itself to the
bread and I can't get it off we've
obviously got the sausages and the bacon
here but there's also some cheddar
cheese some stuffing some cranberry
sauce as
well it's gone a little bit dry now that
it's cold but I actually quite like that
I think the bread is good it's like
crunchy on the outside but nice and
chewy on the inside the pork sausages
have a good flavor you could even go
more generous with the Mayo and I think
that's actually a pretty good festive
sandwich next up we have the Brie and
cranberry for catcha I think this used
to be called the cran marry for catcho
but they've changed it and just gone
straight down the middle let people know
what they're getting it's a sandwich
with some Brie the cranberry Chutney
more spinach again they must have like a
surplus of spinach this year and it's
all served on this Rosemary
fatcha the fater is really dry that
might be mitigated if you eat it it in
store and it's like freshly heated but
like the pigs on the blankets roll still
kind of held up whereas that is quite
difficult to eat when it's cold so and
then the final hot option we have is the
festive Feast Panini T firstly this is
actually chicken isn't turkey we have
bacon there's some stuffing there's a
turkey gravy on here some cranberry
sauce as well and then it's all kind of
melted together with some cheddar cheese
we love a panini in the UK they're like
really popular on Cafe menus as a hot
sandwich option
the fillings work pretty well together
again could probably stand to go for
slightly more moisture I think the theme
has just been a bit dry so far and then
we have some sweet baked seasonal goods
from Starbucks I'm going to request a
quick inmemoriam section here because
For the first time in a few years of
doing these we don't have South Pole Sam
my son has vanished I'm hoping it's a
brief Hiatus rather than a permanent
goodbye I hope he's good wherever he is
with North Pole that as well hope
they're living off their dreams together
this one's for you buddy
Starbucks does have quite a few baked
good options here in the UK for
Christmas we have the Christmas tree
brownie does what it says in the tin
it's a brownie in the shape of a
Christmas tree we have the caramel
waffle muffin this is what I was talking
about when I said the caramel waffle
latte I think was based on these so this
is what the Dutch would call a Stroop
waffle it's these very thin almost like
biscet layers with a layer of caramel
inside to you go to Amsterdam get
yourself some fresh stoop waffles you'll
have a good
time then you also have some tofe icing
and then inside there's like some molten
toffee in the middle as well it's a
pretty good muffin this is the toffee
nut cookie or at least half of
it then finally we have two cookie
options we have of course the classic
Starbucks berer but he's been given a
holiday
makeover Domino's is brought back it's
Christmas pizza for 2023 the fact that
they've brought this back does suggest
that some people are actually buying it
and that it's a commercial success for
for them which I'm a little bit confused
by it cuz I don't think I've ever
enjoyed this thing its official name is
the festive one and it contains a
cranberry drizzle some bacon rashes some
pulled sage and onion turkey onions and
sausage weirdly the thing I probably
object to the most is the Red Onion on
here the cranberry sauce I can almost
kind of deal
with I don't remember exactly how I
reacted to it last time but it's very
sweet I will say I quite like the flavor
of the turkey you definitely get the San
onion which is like what we would
typically include in stuffing in the UK
and the sausage and the bacon are just
kind of there I just think there is way
better pizzas on the menu the best thing
I can say about it is that I think it
looks quite pretty what actually does
kind of excite me on the Domino's menu
though is their new seasonal dessert
these are their Twisted chocolate
cinnamon DBS I think basically what they
do is just take their dough twist it
into these kind of like Twisted dough
ball shapes bake it and then top it with
various seasonings in this case this
chocolate sauce and cinnamon sugar I
mean I love dough balls I love chocolate
sauce and I love cinnamon
so mhm I love the texture of dough balls
I love the crunch on the outside and the
chew you get in the middle I think if I
were ordering a Domino's in the festive
period And I wanted to feel festive I
would swerve the pizza and instead just
get
these when it comes to the holiday
season the US loves to add peppermint
into pretty much everything and Wendy's
is no exception so we have the
peppermint Frosty Cream cold brew and
the actual peppermint Frosty I've never
had Wendy's coffee before so I'm very
intrigued I actually like the taste of
the coffee I just feel like there's very
little flavor payoff from the frosty
that's added into the coffee I'm mostly
tasting coffee moving on we're going to
try the actual peppermint
Frosty it basically tastes like a less
serious version of mint chocolate chip
ice cream so it just has like no
chocolate chips and it's just the ice
cream part it's pretty good it's not my
favorite Frosty flavor I've ever tried
but it's like a fun holiday
flavor KFC has also added a few new
things to its Christmas menu in the UK
this year we'll start with this the
gravy triple bucket it's one big sharing
item in here you get bear with me six
pieces of original recipe chicken one
regular popcorn chicken eight hot wings
six mini fillets two large gravy SA ES
four fries and a drink and then comes
with instructions to let the gravy flow
the bucket's quite fun otherwise they
haven't made too much effort they
actually made a point this year of kind
of addressing the demands for them to do
turkey at Christmas and just said that
actually no we do chicken we're going to
stick to our gun stick to what we know
best this whole thing will set you back
around
£28.99 which is quite a lot of money
although I think it's probably designed
to be shared between like four or five
people so per person cost not too bad we
have two festive Burger options starting
with this one the stuffing Tower Burger
so usually at UK KFC we will have a
tower Burger on the menu however outside
the festive period this just means that
they've added a hash brown into a
regular chicken burger for the festive
period however the hash brown is gone
and it's been replaced by this which is
a sage and onion stuffing Patty I will
say looking at the color of this that
doesn't look like any sage and onion
stuffing that I've ever had in my entire
life we have some cranberry sauce for
some extra festive Twang and that's all
layered on top of a pretty regular KFC
chicken sandwich so you have a cheesy
chicken fillet some lettuce and some
mayo I do not think that a Patty is the
optimal delivery form for San onion
stuffing I say bring back the hash
browns and the other option is the
stuffing stacker Burger so a stacker
Burger in the UK at KFC is basically
just a double burger as you can see it's
got two of these chicken fillets with
the cheese and once again our old friend
the stuffing Patty I think for a chain
that's clearly put some thought into
their Christmas offerings in terms of
you know the packaging and including
things like crabber sauce and stuffing I
think I'm disappointed with the end
result KFC of course is a few festive
menu items nothing really in the chicken
Department what they do have and they do
this every year is a festive bucket for
the chicken it looks cool I think they
always do a good job with the design on
this you got a a sentient bucket of
chicken there with arms and legs that's
bizarre if you see the drum playing
itself with drumsticks w w and of course
the centerpiece is this really cool tree
I'm not complaining because look what's
in the bucket I want to say I would have
liked to see them maybe introduce some
sort of limited edition I don't know
Christmas extra spicy I don't know hey I
don't work at R&D for KFC so I'm sure
there's a reason they didn't do it money
the only like new menu item is this it
is the mac and cheese chicken wrap come
on it was already in every store let's
just put on the menu wraps had them
chicken had it mac and cheese had it put
it together new menu
item I mean who am I kidding that's
great it's their chicken it's crispy I
love it it's their mac and cheese which
is great it's in a wrap which I don't
object to really so speaking of not
holiday specific at least I don't think
there's the Colonel's Homestyle brownie
yo brownies I mean could this be in the
menu all year round yeah but just the
holiday is fine cave always releases
super cool merch from the
holidays I was giving a budget of up to
$40 and the only thing that I could get
that fell into the budget was this fun
holiday bucket hat same idea as the
bucket you got a tree you got a snowman
you got French fries you got these guys
making a Snowman and then you got what
appears to be a snowman that is
self-aware I just don't like wearing
hats really this is as far as down as I
can get it both of my co-workers are
laughing at me so I assume I look great
let's be honest internet let's get a
poll going can I rock this look holiday
stuff aside is Joe a bucket hat Guy
where my bucket hat heads at in the
comments let me know new look or put in
the trash honestly I think that merch
looks kind of sick and I kind of want
some KFC you know it's have to find
me here are all of our exclusive festive
drinks from Duncan so the first drink we
have is the cookie butter cold brew it
has this stuff at the bottom that I
think is the cookie butter syrup but
it's very
dark I mean it's good but like every
other drink at Duncan it is very very
sweet I do like that cookie butter syrup
though it's tasty it tastes like a
gingerbread cookie this is an iced
toasted white chocolate
latte it kind of tastes a little
coconuty but also a little buttery it's
very odd I don't love it somebody out
there will though this is an iced
peppermint mocha I love peppermint mocha
so I'm hoping it's delicious I never get
them iced though I think they taste
better
hot yeah that's really good I'm
surprised that the peppermint syrup
isn't as strong as other peppermint
mochas I've had from other places
because Duncan is like known for doing
the most with the syrups and all the
flavors but this one's actually pretty
mellow this is the spiced cook coffee
and I want it to be good I love spiced
cookies I love gingerbread
cookies it's not
bad I think it needs some sort of creamy
element to make it actually come
together this is that same spice cookie
coffee except it's hot I think it'll
taste better this
way yeah I think I'm right next we have
a hot chocolate with
peppermint
that has a weird
aftertaste that I don't like so this is
a hot chocolate with the toasted white
chocolate
syrup same thing what is going on with
the Duncan hot chocolates why are they
so oily tasting this is the brown sugar
cookie iced try this looks really good I
feel like this looks like a good color
this is the difference between like a
coffee that's you know is going to be
bad and something that looks pretty good
this color theory only applies to Duncan
by the way I feel like if you go to
Duncan a lot you know exactly what I'm
talking
about delicious delicious delicious
wonderful it is a little overly sweet
I've just come to get used to that when
it comes to dunking anything but this is
really good this is the exact same thing
but hot the brown sugar cookie
chai wo no iced it's really delicious
this is the toasted white chocolate
coconut cold Brew I'm not a huge fan of
coconut that's not bad I do feel like
with some of these drinks the iced
version is the way to go just because it
helps it not be so sweet this is the
brown sugar cookie frozen coffee I love
all of the Duncan Frozen coffees I think
they're so tasty and they're basically
kadas they just don't call it that
anymore this is so yummy next we have
the toasted white chocolate iced coffee
this looks like a pretty good color are
we seeing the color theory are we seeing
what I mean
so at Duncan if you get something with a
swirl that means it's a sweetened flavor
additive versus the flavor shots which
are just the flavor with no added sugar
I kind of prefer those to the swirls
just because you can overdo the swirl so
easily and the whole thing just becomes
too sweet but this one is actually a
pretty good balance and last but not
least we have a peppermint mocha hot
coffee the cream that's in it isn't
doing enough to make it like a a creamy
full bodied kind of Beverage it's too
watery I got it on my
pants help and here we have all of the
festive food exclusives at Duncan I'm
going to start with these loaded hash
browns they're calling my name I'm a big
fan of Duncan hash browns so this is
just their regular hash browns covered
with jalapeno cheddar queso and some
chopped up bacon bits this smells
amazing and it's all congealed just give
me a
moment I do wish that there was a better
ratio of queso to actual hash browns
it's all a little bit dry it's a little
salty but it tastes good to me like I
could eat this whole thing in five
minutes moving on we have two wraps one
of these is chorizo and egg and the
other is chicken and roasted pepper I'm
not sure which is which so let's taste
them both let's start with this one the
one that's not a radioactive orange
color it's not bad I think it's missing
a bit of salt but it's actually got a
nice heat to it which I wasn't expecting
I would order this I'm assuming that
this is a chizo and egg so let's taste
it why it's so
orange don't know we dye everything in
this country okay we dye all of our
food I feel like it's a little Bland I
can't really taste much of anything
besides the chorizo this is the maple
sugar snack and bacon Duncan is like the
only place I've ever seen offer bacon
like this like just a little pack of to
go
bacon I assume it's going to be
sweet yeah just tastes like sweet bacon
it's kind of like soggy it's bacon it's
going to taste
good and it does I'm going to eat one
more piece
next we have the maple sugar bacon
breakfast sandwich on a croissant I
really love getting duckin sandwiches on
a croissant I think they toast them
really well maybe this one's a little
too well toasted it's a little burnt oh
you guys that's a little oh no I think
after opening it I don't want to take a
bite of it so let's just move on to the
next thing this is the ham and swiss
croissant stuffer so what I think they
did is just baked the ham ands
inside the croissant and then baked the
croissant instead of just putting it
into a croissant sandwich like this I'm
going to go for the middle cuz I want
the
filling that was such a deep bite and I
didn't get a lick of that ham or that
cheese I just want to oh it's like deli
ham I'm going to taste the
ham I would never get it again
but it's fine one thing we're missing is
the triple chocolate muffin which I
ordered but it didn't come so I guess
they ran out it is a holiday exclusive
at Duncan
though Crispy Cream is celebrating the
20th anniversary of the movie e.l. with
E.L donut collections I love it I love
.l I just think this is just the best
apparently will Ferell held out for more
money cuz he's not involved in this
holiday branding fantastic movie 20
years ago oh God I'm so old anyway let's
take a look at the
donuts the Buddy snow globe donut the
Buddy makes breakfast dut the Christmas
lights dnut and the Santa belly dut this
is just so great isn't this great it's
great so that's another buddy one and
again really smart just the hat and the
feet don't need will Ferell the Santa
belly this is probably a cream filled
one
right Crispy Cream is so good I could
eat this whole box while watching .l and
the second it ends being sad that elf is
over and sad a 12 donuts will put me
into a funk a Crispy
Cream fantastic and of course there are
limited edition drinks at Crispy Cream
this holiday season the main one is the
sugar cookie latte which you can get hot
iced or Frozen and that of course it's
none of these according to the door Dash
guy uh this Crispy Cream specifically
did not have the sugar cookie stuff so
he subbed it with peppermint now I
looked online I didn't see peppermint in
the holiday specific section but I
didn't see peppermint in the non-holiday
specific section either so I'm going to
assume that this is in fact holiday
specific so we got a peppermint latte
hotti
boy oh
whoa I do not like that but look at my
eyes if you really love peppermint you
need to get this drink I'm mainlining
peppermint flavor right now I can't
believe that I need to eat a candy cane
to like bring me down from how much
peppermint is in this good Lord how is
it iced um that can't be right Crispy
Cream just went forget it we're
targeting the most specific audience
with these drinks people where things
can't be pepperminty enough your prayers
have been answered you probably have
noticed jardelli is a very popular fancy
chocolate brand well they have their own
giradelli hot chocolate could be
giradelli there's an H that's
jelli wow this might be one of the best
hot chocolates I've ever had it is so
smooth it is Rich but not too rich this
is way better than any other hot
chocolate I've had certainly anything
you get at a chain restaurant a fast
food
restaurant Crispy Cream I got to say you
get the
dou this
season beyond the fast food restaurants
we also have a bunch of items that
you'll find in supermarkets in the UK
around the holidays the giant Lindor
ball is
back this thing is great but also is
always a recipe for disappointment
because no matter how many times I see
it I always think it's going to be a
giant chocolate ball and it never is how
many Lindor do you think you actually
get in one of these oh actually that's
reasonably generous Lindor I like that
they've even shaped the ball like a
little Lindor with his little
indentations next up we have a festive
Edition Toblerone this is the orange
twist flavor I don't know if these are
as big a thing in the US as they are in
the UK but people do love them over here
in the UK it's usually something that I
might receive maybe as a gift or I will
occasionally Buy in like an airport
dutyfree
lounge I'm not like a huge orange
chocolate guy but honestly this is
really good gentle orangey flavor with
the tobon texture thumbs up for me cab
usually comes up big for the holidays
we've got a couple of items here
including this lovely chocolate Santa
which unfortunately is hollow but you
can also buy Christmas tree decorations
from Cab's it's a bag full of little
edible ornaments do not eat the foil or
the string but within there there is
some milk
chocolate Oreo also has their own house
this is their pre-built cookie house
which is made of their cookies but we're
going to start by tasting some of their
other holiday stuff like the Snowballs
they're like a chocolate filled with an
Oreo filling hold on these look
underfilled awful it doesn't taste
anything like Oreos to me moving on to
the actual cookies we have the classic
holiday Oreos that just have the red
filling and then we have hot cocoa Oreos
which I've never tried before Oreos
always trying the weirdest flavor
combinations to me do you remember that
they did like a Swedish Fish
Oreo look at those two l layers in there
I think that's a fun little touch like
all other Oreos all the cream goes to
one
side it's a better concept to me than it
is in actual cookie form now these I
know and I love what the hell the
serving size for Oreos is two in my
brain I'm going to believe that this was
colored with beet juice and not red Dy
40 I scrape all of the creme off like
that and then I eat the two cookies
together de boo Jesus too moving on we
have the white fudge covered Oreo so
it's a regular Oreo covered in this
white fudge I've had these before and
they're actually really really good I
think it's time to build our Oreo cookie
house so it comes with a couple of packs
of plain Oreos for you to decorate with
so I think that this icing is actually
flavored just like the Oreo filling
these little I think they're like gummy
stars look at these little gingerbread
men in there and then we have a couple
of tubes of red and green icing for you
to decorate with too and then we have
the actual cookie
house oh no our roof caved in a bit but
it's okay I think I can fix it with some
icing oh no it turns out that the icing
in these like cookie gingerbread hous
making kits still sucks skill level one
really easy it's not true the door knob
is ginormous compared to the door this
is the hardest thing I've ever done in
my life they're already all
broken oh my God these stars are hard as
rocks stop zooming in on the house stop
zooming in on the house and here are all
of the exclusive holiday Hershey's
chocolates that I could find so first we
have these bells that are peppermint
bark it's like a white chocolate on top
and then a milk chocolate on the
bottom that is so
good M these little sprinkles that it
has all throughout adds a really really
nice texture these are the mint truffle
kisses so they have like this mint
filling inside of them that is green
that will Skip and these are the candy
cane kisses which are also peppermint
flavored and they have those little
sprinkles running throughout so I'm sure
they taste similar to the Bells these
are the cherry cordial kisses on the
outside it looks like a regular
chocolate kiss but it's supposed to have
that cherry cordial
filling
oh mediciney so these are the sugar
cookie
kisses that's so good it tastes like
cake batter in a good way we have the
hot cocoa kisses which are really cute
so it's milk chocolate with marshmallow
flavored
creeme I know how weird it sounds to say
this as I'm eating chocolate candy but
it's literally just too sweet for me we
also have the Hershey Kisses that are
cookies and cream which is basically
like what their cookies and cream bars
taste like which is amazing calories per
pieces gives you seven you can have
seven kisses and it's only 150
cows
tastes just like the Hershey bar it's
amazing so these are a little different
these are Hershey's hugs and this is a
milk chocolate hugged by white creme I
don't know what that means and I also
don't really want to taste them cuz they
look kind of boring while I was shopping
for these I also saw these really really
cute holiday bars so they basically have
build a Santa or build a snowman you
break the bar apart and kind of put all
the pieces together like a puzzle to
make one of these this is so cute C and
fun Reese's of course have their own
festive shapes I guess starting down
here you can get the Reese's peanut
butter trees chocolate and peanut butter
obviously you can also
get white trees white chocolate and
peanut butter this never looks like the
shape
right uh
yeah okay closer than they normally are
for sure the Reesa snowman get a load of
that and the big boy the chocolate Santa
how many ser do you think is in here 15
do 14 of my co-workers want to meet up
and share
this oh man it's like dry inside didn't
you think it'd be
creamier no rees's has carefully
meticulously perfected the chocolate and
peanut butter ratio in its peanut butter
cup it's all off
here also not available at the Target by
my house you can get Reese's nutcrackers
and Reese's Bells here we have some off
to eights now I'm not sure if if these
were a thing in America or not there was
like an aggressive marketing campaign
probably back in like the 60s or 70s
when they really became like the thing
to give to your dinner party guests at
the end of a meal it's a lot of
packaging it feels like you're playing
par the parcel and the chocolates
themselves are dark chocolate with like
a fondant mint in the middle I mean
these are excellent don't get me wrong
ping the crew would it be weird to eat
like a whole box of these as like a
evening snack just to yourself yeah yes
why is that that's thank you I had a
bunch of my friends were like yeah I
will just buy like a box of after eights
and just like work through them by
myself they do the classic one and you
can also get like a selection box as
well it's a bit of a one track selection
box it's just various combinations of
mint and chocolate we're sticking on the
theme of mint chocolate for a little bit
here because obviously we have the Terry
chocolate orange in the UK we've talked
about this in previous Christmas
episodes but they've also released a
mint ball you know I'm something of an
elf myself they used to have a slogan
which was don't tap it whack
it
taada even compared to an after eight
that's like quite aggressively minty we
talked about quality Street in previous
episodes before but in the UK we have
selection boxes around Christmas where
you get a box that contains a bunch of
miniature individually wrapped
chocolates quality street is one of the
more popular brands of these this one is
inspired by the purple one which is one
of the selection box chocolates you can
get it's milk chocolate shell with some
liquid caramel and a hazelnut in it and
then this one is a collisions bar which
is where they've taken basically the
same the purple one bar but then
collided it with the green one from the
quality Street box and we have even more
holiday themed treats these are all from
Little Debbie so we have gingerbread men
we have brownies we have cakes we have
more brownies and Nutty Buddies so it's
a wafer bar with peanut butter and it
looks like it has some sort of like
white coating on the
outside it kind of reminds me of a
butter finger except less good because
Butterfinger has chocolate we also have
the Christmas tree cakes these are
chocolate these are like the classic
ones I grew up eating these all the time
we have a couple of brownies so this is
the Christmas tree Brownie and this is
the snowflake brownie they're iced
brownies which I feel like they're not
that common and last but not least we
have the gingerbread soft cookies these
are cute little frosted gingerbread
cookies they're really good in my
opinion I know that gingerbread cookies
can be a little divisive Percy pig is a
bit of an icon in the UK it's a suite
that is created by marks and Spencer
which is like an upm Market grocery
chain in the UK but I think the cult
following of Percy Pig kind of extends
beyond the just regular Marks and
Spencers clientele it's hard to exactly
describe the type of sweet that a Percy
pig is I'd say maybe like a gummy candy
and they've released a seasonal version
which is Merry percus which is
effectively just a Percy Pig but with a
Santa Hound but also these are vegan
which is really impressive because like
usually to get that kind of chew you
need some kind of animal gelatin I love
these things I could quite happily sit
here and eat a whole bag of pesy pigs
beyond that we also have marks and
Spencer's festive helpers which I think
is like Percy and friends as well as
Colin the caterpillar candy canes Callin
the caterpillar has been somewhat of a
divisive figure in the UK recently they
found colins old tweets uh we have
caterpillar Cakes as quite a common
thing like for kids birthday parties
marks and Spencer managed to trademark
the name Colin the caterpillar and then
we're kind of trying to extend that to
any Supermarket that was naming a
caterpillar cake anything that began
with a c including chain like Aldi who I
think had cuff at the caterpillar and
they've been involved in a lengthy very
public legal battle over it next up we
have Sainsbury's elf Munch mix cereal
it's a tasty mix of strawberry flavored
elf Hoops choco pops mini cornflakes and
festive stars and you can also get
cracker SL chips SL crisps type snacks
for the holidays so many to choose from
so here we got the the Goldfish holiday
shapes but the cheddar flavor fantastic
the best flavor you can also get another
elf themed pack which is the Goldfish
elf maple syrup graham crackers we also
have the Ritz fudge covered limited
edition Rich crackers Cheetos also got
in the mix this year with their
snowflake white cheddar and the Cheetos
popcorn which is two flavors together in
one thing apparently that's holiday oh
my god I've been eating Goldfish
crackers non-stop for 2 weeks cuz I like
them and my wife thought she is ordering
like a reasonable amount from Costco and
I've again like the box has like three
bags in it now wers have released three
limited edition festive flavors in what
I believe to be varying degrees of
quality or maybe sanity we'll start with
this one which is pigs and blankets
crisps literally just Smoky bacon next
up we have a festive turkey
flavor I think I'm tasting like Rosemary
I'm getting like herbs from this then
I've Save The Best For Last here we have
Christmas pudding flavored crisps
Christmas pudding in the UK for the
American viewers is usually like
simmered fruits which are then kind of
like molded together I don't really like
Christmas pudding anyway I just don't
want to eat raisins in crisp
form oh no all of these are suitable for
vegetarians even the pigs and blankets
and the turkey while we're on the
subject of festive items Gregs also is a
place that pushes the boat out around
the holidays in the UK for those you
don't know Gregs is a beloved bakery
chain it started in the north of the UK
but now has kind of made its way across
the whole country it's very affordable
things are cooked hot and fresh and it's
just very tasty as well they have a
pretty decent range of festive items and
we've got pretty much all of them here
we'll start down this way with the
festive bake bakes might be what Gregs
is best known for in the UK a bake is
puff pastry which is then filled with
some kind of filling in this case it's a
festive filling which I think is a
combination of things like turkey gravy
cranberry sauce and maybe some stuffing
as
well man I love Gregs moving on Gregs
has a Christmas lunch baguette there's
like cranberry sauce some onions in
there the turkey the stuffing and in
this one we have bacon and then we also
have a vegan option with some gravy and
some cranberry
sauce it's okay it's very dry being a
bakery Gregs obviously has some sweet
options as well starting with this one
the festive bun I have some issues with
the naming of this because this is not a
bun this is a cupcake
it's pretty good it's a nice moist
cupcake it wouldn't be a Christmas
episode unless I was mentioning mince
pies and Gregs does a mince pie we've
had this discussion on food Wars
Christmas specials a lot before but a
mince pie in the UK is not made with
mince meat it is confusing some people
actually claim that the original
versions of this did contain meat so
that might be where the name came from
but it might just be one of those weird
British naming conventions somewhat
controversially I don't really like
mince pies a lot of Brits love them I
never really got on with cooked fruit to
be honest next up we have this Christmas
tree biscuit which is very cute I think
it's
gingerbread it is gingerbread it's
pretty festive and then finally we have
a Christmas cake slice this is kind of
similar to a Christmas pudding in that
it's got lots of cooked fruit in it but
as the name suggests it's more of a cake
rather than a pudding it also typically
comes with this very thick layer of
icing on the top when I was a little kid
I didn't really eat the cake itself but
I would go and peel bits of icing off
the top much to the sugan of my
grandparents this is the Sprite winter
spaced cranberry it's their special
holiday flavor which I think is just
Sprite mixed with a cranberry flavor can
I say I don't love Sprite I feel like
growing up you were a Sprite kid or a
Coca-Cola
kid it's actually really
good it basically just tastes like a
fruer version of sprite literally like a
berry
Sprite she's beautiful happy holidays
for myself and the rest of the food boys
team merry Christmas happy holidays and
we'll look forward to seeing you next
year please leave us a like and a
subscribe as a very special present for
me